what have made you feel that you have
accomplished
a form of your goal what what what part
of this
um part of your job of wrapping you feel
you um
accomplish your goal um
i was sitting in the studio session the
other day and one of my announcers was
like you know you number three globally
on youtube
and i was like wow
i was like that's amazing and it's like
the whole my whole life i was trying to
get to this
point and get there and get there and
get down working so hard to get
there i don't know where there is and
then it was like
the place i was trying to get i was
already there
i just seen one i hate to even say who
it was i'm not gonna say well what but i
just seen
a brother that's very dear to me in the
rap game and
he turned up but when i seen him i was
like i don't want to trade places with
you
like i don't like i can dig it
you know i don't want to trade places
with you it's like i was always trying
to get there but i was already there
and it's like my whole life just making
comparisons like
i don't know i'm real competitive you
have to be i'm competitive in
half even this like i look at i look at
when i'm
about to make an album i'm looking at it
like i'm training for a fight
i work out every day it's a night yeah
no six
no alcohol no nothing not like i'm it's
like i'm training for a fight
and i feel like if you make an album and
you're not scared
and you ain't got butterflies in your
stomach and you're not scared
then you're not putting everything into
it yeah that's what they saying fighting
if you're not scared
it's time to stop fighting
you know next time whenever you go in
the ring you don't have that fear
it's time to give it up you're big on
that mic
what do you think what do you think that
is mike what god gives us fear to
protect ourselves
but they feel good when you face it oh
you have to face it
and understand that it's just uh it's
just another part of
just another part of emotion right
fear's an illusion that's what it is
no but would you say is it's another
part of a
it's an emotion that we have to accept
too fear
yeah we have to embrace it we have to
embrace it for me
i like fear because it keeps me sharp it
keeps me polished
and it's like it keep me it's what's
gonna make me push myself to that extra
the extra point if you if you train hard
then the fight gonna be easy
you know if i if i prepared like for
this album i put everything into it i'm
really ready to rep
because i put everything into it blood
sweating
prepare you prepare to fail